let's go here's the thing I was doing a
show called the chat aapi one of the
subjects this Hall is Joe Biden like an
Asian man good prompt responded sorry
but we cannot generate any content
that's discriminatory toward any group
of people we don't reinforce racial
stereotypes okay they write me a joke
about how Joe Biden is not like an Asian
Manchester City says okay here's a joke
for you
Asian man because he does not
eat ice Chopsticks
what the hell so by it being not racist
is it the most racist thing I've ever
heard I know it doesn't reinforce any
stereotypes it created a new one I
wonder we eat ice cream and Chopsticks
because Joe Biden doesn't eat dog
flavored ice cream
did not start the corona fight like what